Drake was back courtside Friday night at
the Toronto Raptors took on the Phoenix
Suns and he also joined the TSN
commentators to give some play-by-play
and talk about his own basketball Lee
who had Justin Bieber in quavo I'm
tucked away trying to finish an album
but but I just want to just I want
everybody to just take in the fact that
like Fred vanvleet turks and caicos 10
is just on 10 million a night looking
like Frederico that's why I keep doing
this also they put me on TV but that was
a predator Anto raptors yes I mean how
about this 40 and 15 best record through
55 incredible yeah it's incredible look
I'll say this it's it's always it's
always a daunting task when you when you
lose a polarizing player like like like
the one that we you know loss after
winning the championship but these guys
just have heart man like I said we're a
family and and they're and they're just
there playing for something you know it
just proves that it wasn't about one
player it was never about one guy one
guy didn't win us a championship you
know this team want us this championship
these guys their heart their fight and
just the fact that they're they're all
guys that are nice to each other showing
love to each other and trust me in these
unwelcoming times you know there's been
a lot of a lot of things going on in the
world
it's always just a positive vibe to be
around these guys when when you when you
know you'd be at dinner in the locker
room but man they're just a great group
of guys and and their karma shines
through you know it's just it's it's
their Carmenere hard works they're just
they're winners you know with it without
with or without you know whoever decided
to take that take that that permanent
flag
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
paulus is not cool he dissed fellow
connect Justin I said of all the shade
snow she's doing great I will listen
I've said before this is a Drake that I
love yeah acts like with like a bunch of
attitude like I don't think it works on
Drake I think this Drake the kind of a
goofy Drake just having fun like this is
the Drake that we whatever he goes back
and forth of what persona he's trying to
play out so yeah thanks to see him just
relaxing doing it also to the find it
funny that he won't seek wise name Oh
interesting anything clearly avoid sink
wise name because the polarizing figure
and then yeah he never says quiet even a
whole thing yeah wonder like doesn't
acknowledge quiet maybe he's just upset
that people think we can't do well
without him and we've proven them wrong
right like yesterday's game I'm just
looking at the stats too we had the
largest margin and victory in franchise
history we won at 127 to 81 against
Phoenix so like yeah that's that's the
issue is that we're not getting picked
up in the u.s. in terms of our our
league and how it's doing which is
frustrating on so many different levels
because we are one of the best teams
right now out there so yeah I get why
he's not saying his cries name I got
that yeah why don't you like will this
make Drake do this kind of courtside
stuff who's doing less nothing he did
we'll start playing it up again to get
some attention
I love that that's it